bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france à leur fin de ce
sommet nous africaine union européenne
avec ce qui a été à décider c'est cette
stratégie globale d'investissement doté
d'au moins 150 milliards d'euros sur
sept ans quelle lecture en faites vous
alors c'est une prise de conscience trop
tardive de l'europe que sa relation avec
sa grande voisine d'afrique pleine
d'incertitude et de doute cette
conférence ce sommet montre que l'europe
a compris qu'elle est devenue un acteur
comme les autres sur l'échiquier
africain et qu'il fallait maintenant
revoir sa stratégie pour revenir en
afrique une nouvelle forme essayez de
courtiser la fiq garder sa place et peut
être gardé ses acquis sur lesquels elle
pensait avoir le monopole depuis toutes
ces années mais il ne suffit pas de
sommet pour récupérer de l'afrique parce
qu'aujourd'hui la fiq et les dirigeants
africains ont confirmé et a traîné
pendant ce sommet que la fiq n'est plus
le monopole de qui que ce soit que la
fiq a maintenant le devoir et
l'obligation de choisir ses partenaires
et d'établir des partenariats avec tout
le monde à travers le monde c'est cette
affirmation qui s'est réalisé
aujourd'hui par cette volonté de
l'europe qui a compris aussi l'europe a
compris qu'elle n'a plus le joint de
compter seulement sur les anciennes
puissances coloniales en afrique pour
garder sa présence de son influence
l'europe a compris que sa politique ce
que sa politique européenne qui est
juste basée sur la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine et la lutte
contre le terrorisme pour pouvoir
justifier ou garder son nom rien ne
suffisent plus que les africains ont
compris que l'europe investisse en
afrique étaient en afrique qui pour
défendre ses intérêts sa sécurité
alors maintenant c'est à l'europe de
prouver et démontrer qu'elle est là
aussi pour un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec l'afrique alors justement
partenariat gagnant-gagnant ya 6 pays
africains qui auront leur propre
production à leur usine de production de
vaccin arn messagers l'europe va aider à
la formation ça s'appelle un dut à
transfert de technologie justement
est-ce qu'on va assez loin sur ce sujet
sachant qu'en plus l'union européenne
refuse toujours la levée des brevets sur
ses vaccins
en effet la pandémie de covile 19 a eu
un grand impact sur l'économie africaine
sur le système sanitaire africain si
aujourd'hui l'europe a fait ce grand pas
pour aider l'afrique a déjà pouvoir
atteindre le niveau 1 dans la
souveraineté de l'afrique à pouvoir se
produire des vaccins contre le vaccin
distribué 25 sans passer par des
intermédiaires ou attendre que d'autres
puissances de la donne gratuitement
c'est une avancée mais cela n'est pas
suffisant il faut aider l'afrique en
étant les vend ses brevets pour que tout
le continent puisse en bénéficier alors
un sommet on le sait en bousculé par ce
repli à militaire de la france au mali
en fin de l'opération antiterroriste
barkan bamako vient me le dire la pelle
la france à retirer sans délai ses
troupes militaires à quel point ses
relations très compliquées entre bamako
et paris peuvent-elles handicapées les
négociations entre l'union européenne et
l'union africaine
non non ça n'aura pas d'impact ça c'est
des relations bilatérales
aujourd'hui si on analyse la position où
c'est que beaucoup de dirigeants
européens ont dit pendant ce sommet
c'est leur volonté de voir que l'europe
puisse avoir toute sa place quelle rap
us avoir sa propre stratégie et non la
stratégie des visites à membres je ne
sais pas si vous avez constaté depuis
fort longtemps il ya quelques puissances
coloniales qui ont leur propre politique
étrangère et les relations avec
l'afrique l'europe était vraiment de
laisser de côté aujourd'hui on voit avec
l'échec de la présence militaire
française au mali avec la perte
d'influencé de la france pratiquement
dans la sous région et d'autres
puissances coloniales l'europe mais
nombreux tant le relais pour pouvoir
affirmer sa présence est peut-être
construire une politique européenne pour
la première fois à africaine
ce qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui l'europe
prépare la main pour pouvoir peut-être
défendre les intérêts de tous les états
européens face à la chine face à la
russie l'inde à la turquie et d'autres
puissances qui sont aussi présentes en
afrique et maintenant si les états
européens agi seul ne la reverront plus
à faire face à cette influence des pays
par exemple comme la chine avec sa
politique de la route de soi qui a
investi des milliards en afrique sur le
plan économique et la russie qui revient
force en afrique avec après dix ans
d'absence les pays du sud comme l'inde
qui vous aussi allez donc du coup
finalement l'union européenne s'est
rendue compte qu'elle n'existe pas
économiquement sur des places sur le
continent africain et qu'il fallait
maintenant peut-être trop tard mais
d'une cette prise de conscience
permettra peut-être de réorienter cette
politique est d'être présente
économiquement pour pouvoir construire
une relation gagnant gagnant avec l'afic
et garder sa place et son influence sur
ce continent de l'avenir des abeilles à
koudougou me merci à vous d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur associé au groupe
afrique de lips merci à vous